okay now this submitting involves
playing Serge I need to show you
something a bit weed though okay let's
start with something that we can all
agree on two plus three is equal to Wow
nice okay so we know what two plus three
is okay
however two or three whole numbers or
things you know with them they don't
necessarily carry on to all the other
kinds of numbers that you know about
example 1/2 plus 1/3 with 2 plus treat
you just go 1 2 3 however many numbers
you need to add and then you just check
them together right but 1/2 plus 1/3 I
know a lot of people you first learn
about fractions one of the common errors
is you just do the same thing so you
like the ones around the top so you go 1
+ 1 + 2 + 3 on the bottom so you go 2 +
3
wait a second 2 over 5 is that what 1/2
plus 1/3 is and of course it's not it's
not true at all what do you have to do
yeah I mean yeah you've got to do a
common denominator thing right you've
got to get these guys talking the same
language like son what we can do 3 6 + 2
6 and then you get the real answer which
is 5 6 you're great so my point is when
you're working with different kinds of
numbers your old rules don't necessarily
apply it you've got to be careful okay
so for example have a think about this
yeah you've got your calculator there I
heard root 2 and root 3 it's about 1.4 I
think in about 1.7 okay
now what does that equal hmm now you
know if you have a look at like out 2
plus 3 which you might be tempted to
think oh it's just root 5 okay but can I
have a look at your calculator go try it
out right yes wait a second group 2 is
what I said well is 1.4 what's there
like that okay root 3 is 1.7 or
something like that isn't it someone
worked it up yeah yeah 1.7 issue so this
is about three point
he's a 3.2 there's a different one okay
3.14
okay now root 5 what is required do you
calculate up again I think you'll find
it's 2 point something it's not root 5
it's something against whatever it is
it's not bad
so therefore Richard Wilson 3 is 5 again
we notice them just like fractions you
can't just take all the same rules and
to make things work okay but I'm not
trying to add these what was the heading
that you just made multiply okay so now
I want you to try this
root 2 times root 3 go ahead punch that
literally exactly into your calculator
and you'll get a number out of that can
you get a number of them look at that
number remember it and then what I want
you to also put in your calculator is
writ syncs and lo and behold they are
exactly equal okay what's going on
what's going on so what you're noticing
here is if you can go ahead try lots of
different numbers by pairs of numbers
what you're finding is this
multiplication just works
it just what so this is a bit weird next
lesson not today I'm going to show you
why this is but for now just like we did
before coming generalizes if you've got
any two sets like this
he's a pair of sense what happens is
amazingly you can take those two numbers
and be for things that are underneath
and you can chuck them together under
the same square root so this is actually
kind of surprising that you're like why
does it work all these things don't work
why is this one work I promise I'll
explain but not today we're running out
of time okay this is one a write up
again
root 2 square so this is the squares for
everything
ah what's going on once it gonna be
little control look at you rule that we
just developed feels just too right you
just go straight back so what you were
okay
root 2 times root 2 it's just to do
cool that was not too difficult have a
look at this next time I it's a little
more challenging because there's more
stuff in the middle bit being squared
okay so I'm actually going to write this
out long form just so that we're clear
on what's happening this is actually
negative 2 times root 7 squared but you
know like in algebra when you write 3x
what you really mean is 3 times X we're
just lazy to say x okay same thing
happening here minus 2 root 7 is minus 2
negative 2 times root 7 okay so I'm just
gonna put the month in multiplication
sign in the X that's worked too long
if that's what that means then squaring
is multiplying something by itself do
you agree so I'm just gonna write the
whole thing all over again like that
okay now I know this is long hair it's
just so if I'm trying to avoid just
giving you a rule and say oh that's why
I want to show you the reasons why okay
all right about 4 numbers 1 2 3 4 all
being multiplied by each other we'll
multiply numbers like a string of
numbers does it matter which order you
multiply them in example 2 times 3 times
5 what is 2 times each other
is that the same as 5 times 2 times 3
yeah it is it's good look 5 times 2 is
10 yeah okay it's all good
multiplication is what we call
commutated do you remember that word
from you 7 means you could shift the
order around it's all good
so therefore over here I'm going to
shift the order around to make it more
convenient to me okay for example
negative 2 and negative 2 you guys are
good these those certs when you multiply
those guys what do you get you get 4
okay the double negatives cancel the 2
does give you the form okay
all right so I deal with these guys what
about root seven times root seven that's
like what we did up here it's seven okay
that's 28 now we put some extra lines of
working and here but in future I think
you can probably go straight to here
Watch
do you see that you see how the whole
things being squared so that means
everything inside individually gets
squared so your squared negative two
gives you poor you square root 7 and you
get 7 and then there's your answer okay
does that make sense okay we're gonna
reverse that process now how long this
route 50 remember this rule that we set
up down here okay
the reason why this is useful is uh
watch what's gonna happen
underneath this square root for reasons
that I wonder if you can work out as I
do it I'm gonna write 50 as 25 times 2
now I can write 50 as 10 times 5 as well
but 25 times 2 is better because 25 is
an important number to me under a square
root what's special about 25 it's a
square number so I can do this square
root stuff alone right I'm gonna use
this rule down here that we were just
exploring and break 1 square root into 2
so it's root 25 times root 2 root 25 of
courses
done okay miss okay last one I'm gonna
turn it backwards so what if I want to
turn this and this into one square root
well 3 is the square root of something
isn't it what's the square root of it's
nine today and then again using this
property we were just exploring I can
turn these two into one by combining at
nine and twenty underneath okay
so nine times 20